good to see you
so
you and i have trouble keeping track of
you because uh
i see you in egypt speaking very fluent
arabic the next thing i know you're in
shikoku
wandering around staying in japanese
inns then you're singing a cantonese
song
but i know that you're very fluent in
spanish and portuguese
and now you're going to take on italia
yep
[Music]
you know one of the things i've learned
from my last few years experimenting
with languages is that
you know the best languages to learn
really are those that you can actually
use on a daily basis and keep up
you know make sense of life and here in
london i meet loads of italians
wherever i go and they're such nice
people and i would really like to speak
it um i think it would be a great thing
for me in my life so that's my project
okay
well you'll be very successful it'll be
easy
we will see there's lots of interesting
interesting factors which
we can get into the only thing i would
say is that i hope you're more ambitious
than just being able to say buongiorno
to a waiter in an italian restaurant in
london because there's so much to
italian culture literature history and
all that stuff once you get started you
won't stop at that like you'll be able
to say bonjourno after it after the
first day but yeah a lot of depth there
that's all
yeah i mean it's a springboard isn't it
there's so many opportunities here to
support i mean you know what it's like
when you meet someone you start off with
when you went last summer
so yeah lots of great stuff
great opportunities
so what's your plan
the plan is so
i think language learning a bit of a bad
press recently because i'm sure well i
know you've seen many other people have
seen this study that came out recently
that said apparently the cut-off
age for learning a new language to
native level is ten-year-old
and you know what
yeah we could debate the ins and outs of
that i've seen a lot of people kind of
pick up on that and almost use it as an
excuse for not learning languages
themselves
uh a number of people in the media have
been saying this and so i thought this
would be a good opportunity to not only
add another language to my uh my
repertoire but also to kind of show
people look it doesn't matter where you
live you can actually learn another
language
reasonably quickly
to a point where you know you can have
meaningful conversations
um you can do it from home you can enjoy
it
um and you don't have to pick up and
move abroad and
you know all that stuff and you also
don't have to reach a full native level
you know you can get to a you can have
very meaningful uh
conversations and relationships with
people
uh
without having to you know spend a
lifetime doing it
you know obviously i couldn't agree more
uh
several points there one learning a
language where that language is not
spoken absolutely i learned mandarin
chinese
in hong kong in 1968 you couldn't find a
mandarin speaker on the streets of hong
kong in 1968.
so if you you if you can immerse
yourself in a i call it creating your
own language world
then you can learn it quite well at some
point of course you have to start using
it but you can build yourself up quite
effectively without being immersed in
the language so that's with regard
therefore to being in an environment
where the language isn't surrounding you
insofar as age is concerned it may very
well be that the eight-year-old is going
to learn it better than you or me
like so what you know i've learned half
of my languages since the age of 60.
maybe theoretically if i had been 10 i
would have learned them faster i don't
know maybe maybe not
it doesn't matter
and but the third thing too is that you
have an advantage because you've learned
all these other languages so you're fit
so it's like if you were to take up a
sport that you've never played before
you're going to learn it fairly quickly
if you're fit if you're not fit it'll
take you longer but nothing prevents you
from getting fit so you get fit by
learning that first language
if you haven't learned any and then you
get better and better at it so you're
going to do very well
it may be that a person who's never
learned another language will will
struggle
but they can also achieve their goal it
just might take them a little bit longer
than then it'll take you
yeah i certainly feel them you know
so i'm not starting from scratch
um so you know i didn't have that but my
knowledge of italian virtually exist you
know it's probably the same as someone
who studied it at school
30 or 40 years ago in that sense i am
starting to
methods of learning so learning through
lots of
exposure to the language
and it's kind of a work in progress for
me because i've used it i've used these
kind of methods on languages that i know
better but this is the first time for me
to
actually arrange from
my aim for the first month of this
project is going to be to do no speaking
at all it's going to be just lots and
lots of um
lots and lots of exposure to interesting
content as interesting as it can be
from you know from from the beginning
level so i'm going to be doing lots and
lots of listening reading
and then we'll see what happens after
that i'm probably going to want to start
speaking
fairly early on but what's interesting
what i'm most interested in is what
happens when i open my mouth after a
month of nothing but exposure to
syria
that's i have no idea what's going to
happen but that's what i'm kind of
interested to see has a first
landmark
well you know i've had that experience
with in a variety of different
situations for example with greek so i
went i don't know three months with
greek then i started speaking of course
you struggled at first but
inevitably my experience whether it be
with greek or or other even more
recently with arabic i spoke to someone
they're all amazed like this is your
first conversation
so so in fact you do better than than
you would think the other thing is with
regard to romanian i had to go to
romania so i had a timetable so i spent
the first month purely input the second
month continuing my input and then
speaking to italki tutors in romania
when i arrived in romania
i was flying like people were you know
amazed and i
i had a great time so so there i had a
constraint i had to do it in two months
so i spent one month on input and then
one month combining input with output
i didn't want my the day i arrived in
romania to be the first time i had ever
spoken the language
so and i think with your background
romanian is close to
to italian in a way but it's not as
close as spanish
and french art to italian
so
it's a very interesting part this is an
interesting sentence
because you know you often
know expansion
you very often get
[Music]
with the background i do have in those
different languages what's going to be
interesting for me to see is actually to
what extent can i prevent that
interference from happens to what extent
can i actually get to the point where i
can speak italian without just
kind of reinventing spanish words
uh in the process that i think is gonna
be a challenge because i've had struggle
in the past separating languages
that's a very interesting point and it i
was i moved into my to speaking romanian
more quickly than i did going into
portuguese from spanish
even though portuguese is much much more
similar to spanish and i think that's
and so that the tendency in trying to
speak portuguese when i had my spanish
was to speak portugal to speak some kind
of a slight adaptation of spanish
and the solution there is when i first
tried to do portuguese i had i bought
this living language and there were a
bunch of disjointed phrases and i bought
a book on how spanish changes you know
the differences between spanish and
portuguese and i tried to absorb you
know these shortcuts and it didn't help
at all
and when i think the many stories we
have at link
which i hope you'll use they're so
effective because they're they're just
daily situations with the most common
verbs in the languages common adjectives
pronouns and you're just hearing this
stuff repeated in silly little stories
about everyday life so you're not trying
to dissect the language how is italian
different from french you're just
allowing the brain to sort through and
get used to it and i think the
transition transition there will be
faster than if you tried to sort of
intellectually parse italian versus
french
well certainly
i i i'm gonna guess that within a couple
of weeks i've been
able to
understand the cinema
learn how to use them both
simultaneously it was almost like
learning a new language in a way because
they learned to keep them separate
in my brain
um but yeah so let's talk about material
because i um
my plan is
you know i'm gonna be in stories
short story books um and so for me it's
stories all the way they have everything
they have the interest factor you have
the repetition the quality use of
language whole language experience
um so my plan is to start with your mini
store is a link because they're written
for exactly that purpose
and what i'm also going to do is usually
to actually track some of my statistics
because
the thing about this project is by its
nature it's quite
uh difficult to pin down isn't it
it's quite difficult to judge progress
so at the very least what i'm going to
be able to do is if i if i'm using links
for
for my input
i'm quite you know strict with with
marking my my known words and things
like that i will at least be able to
track as you've mentioned to me other
day of the email i will at least be able
to track
uh you know painter words read hours
listen to and then words learned
so that's going to be a very interesting
uh
a very interesting
way to evaluate
you know one or two months down the line
to evaluate what's actually gone
you know a couple of thoughts there
first of all
i always quote this lady at the
university of san diego who said the
most important things or the only thing
that's things that matter in language
learner learning are your attitude and
time and the ability to notice but
leaving that aside time
to me the most important statistics at
link are the ones that track your
activity level if you put in if you're
able to maintain a high level of
activity lots of words read lots of
links created all this kind of stuff you
will get there so that's the measure so
at times when i say oh i'm not making
any progress but in fact i've put in all
this time i've saved all these words
i've learned all these words it reminds
me that actually i am making progress so
so that's with regard to those
statistics i think they i even think in
schools they should track the amount of
activity kids put into learning a
language rather than trying to evaluate
their ability to get the subjunctive
rate or whatever it might be
yeah
one thing i wanted to say too with
regard to input
i think that many stories are a great
place to start
and so you know by the way i'm going to
a conference
uh tomorrow in portland oregon stephen
krashen is going to be there and it's
all about storytelling it's story
listening or whatever they call it
but he talks about compelling input we
talk about compelling input but we know
that when you start the input isn't very
compelling
i mean that's just the reality the
really most compelling input is the
genuine authentic if you're interested
in literature if you're interested in
whatever it might be history the you
know
science whatever that you can read
subjects of interest in the language so
you're you're pursuing the subject of
interest and by the way you're you're
learning the language that's optimal it
takes a few steps to get there and
that's why i think the mini story is a
good start and then i think some form of
graded material
where you're not totally thrown into you
know difficult like lots of vocabulary
and yet it's a little more interesting
stories or
when i was learning chinese they had a
graded history reader in chinese and
stuff like that if you can have that
little step
then it takes you from the beginner
material to the authentic material so
compelling input is a great story but in
fact we've got to gradually
move ourselves into the genuinely
compelling
yeah
exactly and i think that's like
if it was
arabic or chinese you know
is really
really really interesting because it's
achievable given the language in
question and my
and also when you are into that
authentic material this is the amount of
variety in the exposure as well just
kind of balloons
um so we've got the we've got the mini
stories that link to kick off with i
don't know how long they'll last me like
a couple of weeks i guess you can always
go back to them to refresh to review
yeah yeah so those are my series of
great readers i had italian reasons for
beginners and intermediate i always have
my conversations material which is more
kind of dialogue based i'll make a point
of documenting all these resources that
i use because um
um i i was emailing the crash on the
other day and he
i was asking about this and he said the
thing that most people are going to want
to know
most likely is where do you get your
your compelling comprehensive input from
you know that's a big thing so i'm going
to make sure to document all of this so
that people can at least for italian and
go back and see you know what i've used
but then very quickly i want to start to
move on to
my real aim i think is to get to
authentic material which i would be
consuming in english anyway but to kind
of get to it in italian so for me that's
well you know
most of what i do actually is just going
to read the news and business books
that's basically what i do so i guess
i'll try and do that in italian and see
what happens now one of the problems is
when you get into authentic material
there's a lot of authentic material
which is text without audio and then
there's a lot of authentic material
which is audio with no text for example
of course newspapers or articles that
you can find and
in my case i would import them in the
link
or audio like uh rai raidu has the
series aleoto de la sera which is
phenomenal 20 episode things on roman
emperors and you name it but there's no
text there there's no transcript
so in between you've got something like
il naratore
who puts out these audio ebooks so you
have both the audio and the ebook and of
course the ebook can be imported into
link and you can do all your usual
linking and statistic keeping and so
forth
so but then at some point you graduate
beyond that and you just consume audio
or just consume text
sure yeah yeah um
let's talk about time see like it's like
this particular moment in my life i have
a luxury time okay more than i usually
so from your experience with this kind
of method is there an upper
daily limit like beyond which you find
yourself just kind of zoning out or not
being able to focus
well when i studied chinese
i was going at it six seven hours a day
when i was learning mandarin
but i had three hours in the classroom
and then i put in another three four
hours at home
but i was possessed right
so i learned it in a year learned four
000 characters i was reading novels and
the whole thing but i was possessed
i think like right now i mean i'm not
working i could put as much time into
arabic as i wanted but there's family
there's friends there's a whole bunch of
stuff if i manage to get in two hours
that's a good day
and a good a good part of that is just
listening when i'm
cleaning up around the house or um in
the car or or whatever
so i think if you can get in two to
three hours a day
then and and i think the the satisfying
thing in your case with italian you'll
move through it very quickly like arabic
for me is tough but but for you and you
can go into the mini stories
you'll understand it all
but you still have to work on the
phrases that's why i think the
activities if when you do if you do the
flash card the activities you should use
is the reverse flash card like starting
from english into italian
and the dictation where you hear the
italian and you got to write it out that
forces you to concentrate a little bit
more whereas the flash card you can just
flip through them
but for you
yeah you'll go quickly and we like it
when we're having success if i'm sitting
there and i keep forgetting the same
arabic word get discouraged but with you
you'll fly through that stuff and pretty
soon you'll be onto your graded reading
material and pretty soon you'll be onto
things of interest
and and so you won't be fighting as much
resistance so i think you'll find that
you'll be spending two to three hours a
day
yeah
because i wanna i don't
because often one big objection that
people would have to
you know say well like it's myself who's
got three hours a day to send a language
is one to two hours of
you know sit down
focus study because that's on the upper
end of what most people achieve
but then being quite being quite um
determined
in using my my you know my down time
to get that extra input so you know if
i'm on the you know i
when i go to my co-working space here
i'm on the train or i'm commuting for
about 45 minutes so that's an extra hour
and a half of input right there every
single day and then you know watching tv
in the evening i don't do much off but
if i do then i'll do that
so trying to
again like the opportunity with italian
because it's
less of a belief
for me perhaps is that that authentic
input i can maybe access it a little bit
earlier on that i might be able to with
other languages so there is value there
in in
just more general
mean i would listening 70 of my language
learning time is just plain listening
and one little bit of advice when you do
whatever you're doing on link whether it
be many stories or stuff that you bring
in
create a playlist
because the playlist will track your
hours of listening
if you just
bring it into itunes you won't be able
to track how many minutes or hours you
actually spent listening so it is
interesting to have a statistic of how
much you're listening every day and yeah
if you put if you create the playlist
that playlist keeps track of how many
times you listen to that
item and you get a total hours listed
yeah and with all the material we've
mentioned with you many stories of my
great readers my conversations between
audio and contextually imported
if you're listening while reading it on
the site
but if you simply take that audio and
put it into itunes and listen on your
whatever mp3 player it can't track that
so whereas if you create a playlist it
tracks it
okay and if you have your graded readers
if they are under copyright you can't
share them in the library but you can
import them for your own purposes
exactly and that's what i did with
assimil i imported assimil imported the
audio files but i can't share it with
anyone
if you can get the file as an epub or
whatever a pdf and then i go to calibre
and caliber i convert it to a text file
and a text file i can import it
yeah you have to go through caliber
wouldn't it be a good word where
everything you have to add
it where you want it to
you know i guess i'm moving
you should have a website where i can
come on pay you for your graded reader
and then be able to download both the
audio
and the text in a format say that i can
use it link
yeah yeah that's a really that's a
really really good idea yeah yeah anyway
routledge by the way does that to some
extent
you can download audio from revlit
which is unless you have their text but
at least that's a start
and i think i also buy the ebook version
so i can go to routledge i can buy the
ebook version of for some of their books
say even in arabic i can buy the ebook
version and i can download the audio
free like they give you the audio
heading in the right direction
yeah you see one of the things that i'm
thinking about
[Music]
you know
obviously we you know we make videos and
we put them online
i don't know whether you feel when
you're doing these projects would you
feel any particular sense of pressure to
perform so to speak
i'd quite actually like to enjoy this
project for me i've had a very busy few
years now i'm kind of quite looking
forward to this project is something i
can enjoy
you know i've never enjoyed
i've never enjoyed languages ever as
much as when i first started learning
them back when i was you know 20 years
old with no pressure it was just pure
people kind of fun so i've been kind of
wondering how to both like make it
useful and document it whilst also you
know be able to enjoy it rather
selfishly myself it's a very good point
like
when i started russian i didn't have my
youtube channel or anything i for a year
i didn't speak russian
and i was on my own schedule and i
started listening to audiobooks you know
uh
turgenyev or whatever it might be
no pressure but now because i've got
this following on youtube i kind of jeez
when i start speaking arabic you know
people are going to be poking holes in
my arabic when i speak russian there's
always someone who comes in to point out
that i messed up whatever point of
grammar so yeah i think we learn
languages for ourselves
uh a lot of the sort of input side of it
is tremendously enjoyable because we
access a whole new world even for even
my limited arabic i have a better
understanding of quote the arab world
than i had before it just comes that
little bit closer so most of the rewards
are personal
and when we speak it's to communicate
it's not to perform
and that's why i i never criticize
anyone's performance so to speak whoever
comes on and speaks i can speak language
xyz
fine good for you you know clap however
well you speak it that's your thing it
doesn't matter so i think we have to try
to step back and not say i'm going to
demonstrate how clever i am because i'm
going to learn italian in three months i
think that's not the issue
the issue is to encourage people to say
here are the different ways
non-traditional ways that you can enjoy
language learning and you can make
progress whatever that might be
and it might be fast for someone like
yourself who has other romance languages
there might be people who are even
faster luca could probably go out and
learn mongolian in a couple of weeks uh
but that's fine everyone you know goes
at their own speed
yeah
yeah well we'll see i mean
measure for me
and um
uh actually kind of documenting that
i've been asking people some suggestions
one question
uh are you gonna document your very
first attempt to speak
or are you gonna wait until you have had
three or four under your belt
i'm gonna document the very first one i
don't think he's gonna be very
informative
i mean in the sense that it's just a
snapshot but i'm gonna i'm gonna when i
do speak for the very first time after
one month it will be on camera i'll make
sure that
and i'm just again i'm just gonna have
to
fight my
kind of conditioning to kind of perform
you know just i just try to make it as
natural as i can
one suggestion you know if you make a
video your very first time speaking
italian
then of course you're going to stumble
and all and that sits up there on
youtube and people come in and say are
he's here for lousy
it it might be an idea to sort of create
a bit of a portfolio where you
take you know two minutes of your first
and then two minutes of the second time
and have this sort of
take the first five of them take two
minutes of each and make it one video
i think that would be more interesting
than just putting one video up there
where you struggle and um and ah and
speak spanish and
all the things that are going to happen
it's just a thought that's interesting
so there could be like conversations
over there you know
over the course of a week for example
whatever so that because your fifth time
is going to be remarkably better than
your first time
and so rather than leaving that first
time up there
and people come they find your video and
then who's this guy he's an he's
supposed to be a polyglot he doesn't
speak italian very well
whereas if you have here is this
progression
you know time lapse progression of five
conversations and then they'll see how
much because you're going to activate it
so quickly
i can assure you with with this
intensive input you're going to activate
it very very quickly and that will be
interesting to see
yeah that's a really good idea i'm gonna
i'm gonna definitely definitely think
about that because yeah
[Music]
people
no one wants to sit and watch reading a
book
if you're going to speak to someone
every day for five days week one week
one is one video a minute and a half two
minutes of each 10 minute video
there you go
all right
get started all right yeah i'm looking
forward to hearing more
about how things go well let's check in
and let's check in in a month then
okay
[Music]
you